começo então paulo inicia se o
astrofísico eleja mais ou menos no final
da minha parte curricular não estavas em
portugal para fazer investigação
inicialmente conhecia são mais júnior
comandou treinamento depois como pós doc
voltar a portugal
seis anos depois e fez anos depois um
que é mais a luz aos tempos
entrai populares queríamos a ensinar
física eef de que o ensino é uma física
é é quem tem a ver com o magnetismo
ensinada desde que o cão saiu em cima
fiquei um tempinho espantado porque é
dinâmica que nós queremos na nem
interessa não é toda a minha existência
é isso é certa maneira a estreia de uma
considera normal e durante muito tempo
tentar e usar o mesmo a mesma abordagem
que usava para investigar pra vocês
terem uma idéia do que é o ensino
vocês não verão em um ímã no acho que é
uma mão segurando um ímã e eu atirei
isso há um circuito o que vocês queriam
ver alguém era ruim mas nada para trás
batendo o que eu quero é que ele mais se
ouvia ia passar correndo que não se
cuida direita é e esta idéia aqui é uma
idéia que parece que é uma idéia
extremamente anormal como é que é
possível um imaginava no inverno aqui
não toca no circuito parece que não
circuito é uma lei fundamental
nós temos energia elétrica vivo isso é
assim que funciona a barragem é é assim
que funciona
é o ponto que eu queria que vocês
guardassem inglês wise é que o preocupe
se ver o que está aqui parece urgia eu
preciso nenhum cara conselhos que são
invisíveis
existem coisas que são tão materiais
como esse comando que são invisíveis e é
essa quantidade que são invisíveis são
elas que vão gostar acontecer e é isso
que eu tenho que ensinar
tem que ter que aprender o que é que
está livre invisível o que explica esse
fenômeno que para vocês terem uma idéia
do que está lendo invisível aparece ali
umas linhas não vou entrar em detalhes
mas essa coisa invisível aquele está e
está a facturar correto do circuito é é
um fez o que explica o que está a
acontecer e não basta evocar o invisível
para aprender o que eu acho que nós
queremos aprender mas ainda é preciso é
mais tão ele investigava matemática
outro longo simples mas não houve
algumas equações para impressionar é
real e nada eu explicar o que acontece
quando eu estou explicar os fenômenos os
planos início que eu não tenha chegado
espécie de ensino
ninguém percebia nada e era normal que
não estivessem estava a ter lugar um
fenômeno que se chama sul carga coletiva
que o prende mais tarde que existia nem
sequer tinha essa noção do que é ser
careta nem positiva
imagine que você acerta uma capacidade
infinita que eu saí da informação porque
todos nós humanos somos pessoas 500 mas
ea na altura nós começamos a receber
mais informação no nosso e conseguiu
expulsar
quando isso acontece nós não conseguimos
perceber nada e isso é algo que é com um
inspirado na minha cidade aprendemos
conceitos que são boas ferramentas
sofisticadas não tinha um centavo nem
será que o sapé livro coisas mais
simples a uma substituição como o sexo a
criar e então é a minha grande
- esforço grande enfoque foi como é que
eu vou conseguir resolver esta super
cadê a comitiva está ligada à o ensino
do concelho este gajo é é a primeira
coisa que eu pensei em fazer de facto já
existe certa maneira está implementada é
que o que chama o ensino construtivista
eu estou ensinar uma coisa muito
sofisticada que vou fazer gol para ter
um empate e vou ensinar e isso cada uma
das partes fazendo uma ligação com os
quatro postulantes à vaga e assim alguma
quanto é do nosso conhecimento esse
tempo pra esse conhecimento novo e
depois mais tarde isso combina para
enfiar um conhecimento que eu diria que
é bastante se explicar mas isso não é
suficiente é a abordagem construtivista
não é subsídios suficientes do facto é
continuar a informação num simples um
caso nós temos um caso que acontece se
eu tiver essa situação
são coisas muito complicadas e mesmo
assim não funciona então o que eu pensei
fazer foi fazer viveu e chegada que
consegue pensar que o vídeo eu queria
fazer e sei essas experiências e quando
nós fazemos crianças é normal que as
crianças não não funciona em uma uma
parte importante experimentar diz fábio
é facto que perceberam que não funciona
e iluminar o que não funciona isso é uma
coisa fundamental ea primeira é que o
que foi vamos filmar uma aula completa
vocês já imaginaram ocorre o uso ea
minha aula é assistiu ao uma hora e meia
e passado uma hora e meia ideia pra casa
ver o professor mais uma hora e meia
para uma coisa é nós cometemos um erro e
um erro
havia também um problema
ela queria tecnológico nós tentamos
fazer estragos em 2005 e vocês imaginem
quanto é que o dia 2005 que acho que não
existe o tubo ensinada nisso tentar
servir vídeos tentar fazer a montagem do
vídeo a transferência e tua ainda um
filme de uma hora e meia era
simplesmente impossível e não funcionava
e depois nós fazemos essas crenças nós
como gêmeos facto em algo que é um vírus
muito focados que iriam até o máximo 18
20 minutos e só vocês pararem de emitir
máximo por um vídeo é de fato a esta
ideia do que é uma idéia que nós estamos
discutindo é que o o oscar é isso que um
vídeo mais ou menos 15 minutos e um golo
é um número interessante e que agora nós
temos alguns países um vídeo foi feito
depois de aprender com os nossos erros e
só separar o que é que existe neste
velho existem esquemas mas fazer uns
três anos a situação física é e preço
nós descrevemos equações que descreve o
que está a acontecer física e usa muita
matemática e ao que vocês não vai mas é
o nadador que está a falar e explicar o
que está a acontecer e isso é o que é
fundamental se vocês pararem um
estudante está a tomar notas no seu no
seu caderno de apontamento do curso está
a aplicar tomará algumas notas mas o
professor tem um mérito de informação
muito crédito
ok está ainda costuma escrever no quadro
pode haver barulho uma acústica nessa
aula o colega no havaí que começa a
falar uma distração gosto né
por acaso isso ia estar mais cansado
tempo na internet até mais tarde e o que
é importante ter em conta é que nós
ao fazermos este texto vídeo criar o que
é enviar informação em que o estudante
tem total controle sobre ela e
informação
muito mais informação do que está aqui
do que está escrito um livro ou está nos
apontamentos de qualquer estudante ou
mesmo do professor é que o que explica a
um ponto também é importante é que está
ali a cara de uma pessoa eu criei
fundamento que este também é que nós
temos realmente que há um ano do médio
para humanos que o fator humano é de
facto fundamental
o que nós aprendemos com esta com esta
com esta espécie dos filhos aprendemos
muitas coisas que aprendemos que o
substantivo querem ter uma espécie muito
rápido à informação
eu faço parte da geração google
estudantes fazem parte da geração
youtube seja querem procurar alguma
coisa eu falo que me ajuda busca do
youtube ou algo como eu ou a além disso
é é aprendermos e nós já sabíamos disso
que o transferência de informação é
completamente assegurada pelo vídeo não
é se eu quiser consultar a informação
não não perde nada em usar o vídeo usar
uma um alguém perfeitamente normal assim
como eu
mexe é a outra coisa muito importante
que se ganha com vida entender com a ok
um sinal que é continuar é o nosso
sucesso da aprendizagem não tem um
controle muito grande do que se passa em
uma sala de aula a um centro que faz uma
exposição aos inscritos dúvidas mas não
há um controle total enquanto que aqui
no vídeo a 1 contra o tal eu vou ver o
verde quando eu quero
vejo as vezes que eu quero e isso cria
uma pressão psicológica e faço gosto da
jal ver este vídeo e os fatos vão
acreditar nelas que nós nós vimos isso
está alinhado mas quando é que o estado
espírito eu ficava no meu estado de
espírito e faca numa escola de
engenharia
nós que não queremos só transmitir
informação que nos transmitem está
inscrito e está escrito que consegue que
nós temos o nosso destino nas nossas
mãos
é pois fazer isso aconteceu
caso quando eu fiz este vídeo sem
problemas antes da data popular que
fazer investigação e quando voltar ele o
pai que os vídeos andavam por lei
isto é os estudantes precisavam ser
emocionante é já é porque não estava a
dar aulas
usávamos filhos e continuam a usar esses
filhos ea mãe início é apreciável no
começou apesar de não ser o seu
professor e é uma coisa que é bastante
agradável professor e mesmo aqui ao que
considera profundo na nossa profissão é
ver um genuíno preço por um estudante
sobre o que aprendeu a conosco e quando
eu voltar e é para aí que nesta altura
mais ou menos em 2011 estava a ter lugar
é o projeto engenheira um minuto para um
sexo tinha como objetivo criar 250
vídeos de um minuto na divulgação de
engenharia que acertou na escola estava
a ser premiada com essa função vídeo os
centros estavam fazer vídeos de
divulgação científica e quer uma idéia é
fantástica
então nós aproveitarmos essa essa está
de espírito de estado da cultura e fomos
avançar com o projecto 20 é o que quero
este projecto 20 do projeto 20 era
permitir a qualquer o centro da escola
que se entender se de criar o seu
próprio vídeo e havia várias regras que
a primeira regra é que os vídeos em
português é nosso
não não nos esquecermos que o português
é é uma língua fantástica
os portugueses são fantásticos e que
isso é uma vantagem competitiva
fantástica
num mundo global e nós tivemos em língua
portuguesa vencidos para melhor e apesar
de uma escola centro de engenharia é
suposto toda a gente falar em inglês
quando ele sai outro e a pressão nas
laterais e eu tive que clara ao todo em
inglês méxico esse ponto pra nós a
importância e é israel criar um vídeo é
que eu posso transferir aquela
informação offline
já não sinto deve estar a falar sobre
quem não quer
em particular na aula e vou ter mais
tempo na aula
o ter mais tempo na aula pra que vou ter
mais tempo para interagir com meus
alunos o que querem interagir com com o
estudante está numa sala de aula é o
primeiro ponto é ouvir ouvir por nossos
estudantes que elas têm para nos dizer
que este facto está em raciocínios
completamente lógico sem falhas só o um
dado a se numa dada situação física mas
que não funcionam e não funcionam porque
o fato o que está a se estudar morou
sexo é ser compreendido e é normal que
alguém esteja a estudar aquela assunto
pela primeira vez tenham do símio lógico
mas que não não funciona exatamente como
filmar uma aula de uma hora e meia era
uma coisa perfeitamente lógico mas não
funcionava e é essa interatividade entre
os alunos punhos suas idéias discutir
suas idéias com os outros e criticam um
ponto a menos e daí é é um mal que é
muito importante nas aulas que o vídeo é
algo que está a falar em do vídeo em que
veio primeiro
no final do projeto nós tínhamos mais
tem vídeos faz e eu fui fazer um
cadastro e ainda do do canal do processo
no youtube e o primeiro vídeo de
campanha parece alertas muito fininhas
está em 39 mil mas que afinal mil
visualizações
o que é fantástico objeto o vídeo está
lá a acertar dois anos mas é
impressionante como a 32 e 39 mil
visualizações e um casos é final do
particular mas os vídeos têm a contar
mais 10 mil visualizações chegado aqui o
que eu queria concluir sobre a sociedade
e os vinhos são importantes porque
permitem transmitir informação mexe além
deste país que costumamos dizer que é
corriqueiro a um espectro de um sinal do
caráter controle das nossas vidas como
estudantes a aprender qualquer coisa que
os vídeos planeta
isso é algo que eu não estava tão à
espera e que entende com esta
experiência
além disso a aprender que os vídeos
faziam com que os estudantes não
valorizassem mais como professor e essa
escala é a razão pela qual estou aqui
agora deixando uma mensagem pro futuro
nós precisamos fazer vírus que esse
vídeo com sua esposa 200 e técnicos
agradeço todo o país mas não não existir
nenhum isto é é é não sei quanto técnica
ajudar na feitura dos filhos
nós temos que passar para uma fase entre
andar um envolvimento real estudantes
onde o primeiro lewis se envolve na
feitura do vídeo um vídeo não precisa
ser necessariamente um centro fazê lo e
isso pra mim parece ser um passo e
importante e custos a fila zero no
futuro